grab some delicious clemato juice and
make out with your emotionally unstable
girlfriend because we have a show with
more holes than amber heard's testimony
amazon's outer range is like if lost had
a baby with a cowboy and in this video
we're gonna take a deep dive into its
ending and some of the show's biggest
unsolved mysteries but before we do make
sure to like and subscribe every little
bit helps the channel out the final
episode is called the west which really
has a double meaning not only is it a
reference to royal abbott's western
pasture where a series of supernatural
occurrences occur but to the early
settlers the wild west was seen as the
great unknown an expanse of land waiting
to be discovered and this whole notion
of the known versus the unknown is one
of the show's biggest themes in the very
first episode josh brolin's character
royal abbott recounts the story of
kronos the greek god of time and how he
created a terror in the earth which
separated earth from heaven the known
from the unknown episode vii is actually
called the unknown and autumn will later
refer to it as its gatekeeper an ominous
billboard can be found in the final
episode which states america tells you
that the only things worth knowing are
those which can be known america is
wrong so the whole acts as this portal
between the known and unknown we have
characters like autumn who welcome it
and see it as something good while royal
fears it to get a better understanding
on how this hole operates let's take a
look at the evidence the hole seems to
be meant for those who want to disappear
the only two living people i'm not
counting trevor's dead body who we've
actually seen go into the hole are
eight-year-old royal older royal who is
actually pushed into it by autumn and
perry both eight-year-old royal and
perry were running from something they
wanted to disappear you could even argue
that the bison who come out of the hole
in present day were running from being
hunted as sheriff joyce sees this in the
past we'll get to that in a bit and the
hole seems to disappear when the person
it wants jumps into it the whole also
doesn't seem to be consistent in where
and when it drops its traveler
eight-year-old royal is transported from
1886 to 1968 but when older royal jumps
in he doesn't jump nearly that far into
the future so there doesn't seem to be a
consistent every time you jump in the
hole it throws you x amount of years
into the future kind of thing the hole
also seems to affect how fast or slow
time is experienced around it there's
only one brief example of this and it
occurs in episode 1 when royal first
hears the rumbling of the whole it's 8
am when he leaves the ranch but when he
comes back it's 10 am what was maybe
only a half hour for him turned into two
hours the hull's connection with time is
also something extremely valuable and
this is something we see with royal's
brief jump into the future in episode 2.
it may also be by wayne tillerson royal
abbott's neighbor is so adamant on
getting royals land when royal is pushed
into the hole he wakes up surrounded by
heavily armed soldiers there's a giant
countdown timer here almost as if those
in the future were expecting him the
place is also surrounded by what appears
to be large oil drills however i don't
think they're drilling for oil but for
that black ooze luke finds that gives
people visions of the past and future
the solid version of this ooze is what
royal finds in autumn's necklace and
what billy feeds to his father sheriff
joy also follows this black trail which
leads her to an absolutely wild panorama
of her ancestors hunting bison as far as
we know sheriff joy never went through
any hole so how is she back in time my
guess is one of two things either this
is just a vision of something that has
happened in the past and this occurs
because she has been ingesting some of
the black stuff around her when it wears
off she'll probably come back to normal
however it's also possible that this
group of native americans went through
the hole in their time sometime in the
past and have now arrived in our present
day she could also be back in time she
does check for self-service and gets
nothing remember that weird guy frank
who asked the sheriff to investigate his
land because someone he knew said they
found a mastodon in a cave on his
property well in his discussion with the
sheriff he talks about how the mastodon
went extinct around the place to seen
era also known as the ice age funny
enough this is also the area bison were
first discovered so this hole has likely
been here for tens of thousands if not
millions of years hell one of the
episodes even begins with images of
wyoming being transformed over millennia
just throwing this out there but we also
don't know if there's more than one hole
or if there are other places which act
similarly like a cave for example but i
want to go back to this vision royal
sees of himself dying there he's in
cecilia's arms and autumn kneels over
his body check out the yellow outfit
she's wearing in episode 2 autumn refers
to yellow as being a color of strength
and when asked if she was ever part of a
cult she says yes in royal's trip to the
future we see autumn wearing this same
outfit surrounded by similar cult-like
members all wearing the same necklace
with billy joining adam as the first
member of our cult in episode vii it
appears autumn is the leader and now
that we know that autumn is royal's
granddaughter amy who has come back from
the future things like amy's drawing of
heaven which shows men and women in
yellow outfits start to make a bit more
sense yes one of the biggest reveals of
the season is that autumn is amy
something that becomes evident to royal
when he finds the scar on her forehead
one which she got when her father and
royal got into a fight there isn't much
we know about autumn and we can't take
what she says at face value but let's
take a look at some of the evidence
autumn arrives at the abbott ranch
looking to camp with a [ __ ] ton of money
she carries books on quantum physics and
takes a drug called lamotrigine commonly
prescribed for those suffering from
bipolar disorder she's also a poet which
will see her recite a very strange poem
later on she'll tell royal that she
doesn't remember anything before the age
of 9 which is funny since royal says the
same thing about himself which we know
is a lie autumn might be lying too i
guess she remembered those words her
father taught her sometimes you keep
things from people you love because you
don't wanna you don't wanna hurt them
autumn probably knows a lot more about
this hole than she's letting on and she
may even have known that throwing royal
into it wouldn't have killed him autumn
also has someone she's in touch with
someone she refers to as mom and this
person is supplying her with money near
the end of the final episode amy's
mother rebecca mysteriously reappears
after being missing for several months
if amy is autumn then we can assume this
mystery woman autumn is talking to is
rebecca there's not a lot we know about
rebecca but she does tell amy that she
had to leave in order to hide all we
really know is that the night she left
she got in a big fight with perry and
never returned home so something big
happened here which forced her to leave
her daughter whom she loved very much
like royal autumn says when she was 9
years old that she was in quote some
sort of accident which makes her not
remember anything before that time royal
accidentally shot his dad and ran into
the hole does young amy do something by
accident something bad which leads her
to jump into that hole and become the
autumn we see here in present what's
strange about royal's death is that it
looks like cecilia understands and knows
that this has to happen just look at the
way she nods it's like yep i know it's
his time to go she's accepted it and for
all we know she could be in on it during
royal's trip to the future we also get
some other interesting information from
cecilia who confirms that this land is
no longer theirs and this might have
something to do with perry's bail since
the abbots used their ranch as
collateral to post his 500 thousand
dollar bail for the murder of trevor
tillerson because perry throws himself
into the hole and subsequently
disappears their ranch will be taken
from them and put into the hands of
either the state or the bank i think
that means either autumn or the
tillersons will use their money to take
over the land allowing a mining company
called by9 to experiment and extract the
land's resources this is the same
company royal found the mineral expert
had worked for when he went searching
for answers as to what the mysterious
substance found in autumn's necklace was
i'm curious if this mining company has
anything to do with the mysterious
disappearing mountain from episode 3.
now this occurs exactly as royal and
autumn shake hands almost as if them
meeting has caused some distortion in
space and time since the area
surrounding the mountains seem to be
filled with this rare black material it
could be surmised that the mining
company has extracted the entire
mountain itself so when royal and autumn
shake hands it's part of autumn's world
future seeping into the present there is
one other time where autumn and royal
shake hands when royal agrees she can
stay on his land a few episodes later we
hear a crazy story about this guy's meth
addicted cousin who vanished for six
seconds and then reappeared this
probably happened during that first
handshake and his disappearance was a
result of him being dead from drugs in
the future it's a really small thing but
i think it tracks with the disappearing
mountain before royal is so
inconveniently shot by luke tillerson
cecilia tells him to run but there's
something i saw here that was super
interesting i'm pretty sure that's wayne
tillerson the owner of the rival ranch
who suffered a stroke near the end of
the season he looks to be completely
recovered and isn't even using oxygen
like he was before the stroke remember
that billy was feeding him that black
crushed up powder i wonder if it has any
healing potential as well near the end
of the episode royal shoots billy while
autumn is in the passenger seat and
their car crashes before a giant
stampede nearly kills both royal and
autumn royal was going to kill autumn
here until he discovers that it's his
granddaughter he almost made a terrible
mistake just like he did with his father
when he was eight and remember how he
didn't have the strength to carry his
dad and instead ran away here royal does
have the strength grabs his
granddaughter the person he almost
killed and brings her back home instead
of running away he's facing whatever the
future may hold literally he's holding
someone from the future at home however
cecilia is pissed she can't find amy or
perry and red is leaving town to be with
his girlfriend everything she has loved
is gone she's also gone from devout
christian to non-believer conversely
royal has gone from non-believer someone
who would stay at the back of the church
and just read the paper during the
sermon to believe her and cecilia knocks
over the dinner table a symbol of the
family once being a cohesive unit now
shattered on the floor now cecilia says
that her family is gone but if you
believe what autumn told perry nothing
is ever really gone she said that
rebecca is not gone
then nothing's ever really gone what do
you mean by that perry
maybe nothing's ever gone the season
ends with an earthquake we saw one of
these earlier in the episode around the
time of rhett's bull riding i think that
one of these earthquakes means a hole
has either opened or closed one of these
earthquakes could be rebecca coming back
for amy and the earthquake at the end
could be rebecca taking amy back through
the hole i can't wait to be proven
completely wrong in season two now you
might ask yourself how could this be
rebecca coming from a different time if
we already saw autumn talking to rebecca
earlier that day on the phone it can't
have a cell phone and call across time
periods so this would mean there are two
rebeccas just like there are two amy's
so can it not be assumed there are
doubles of other characters finally a
last bit of wtf to inject into your
brains we never really know what
happened to royal's mother and sister
and since they lived on the same land
that the tillersons and the abbotts
currently occupy it is definitely within
the realm of possibility that royal
could be related to the tillersons or
any one of the abbots including cecilia
which could be just gross but hey it's
wyoming there's not much to do there now
i want to open the floor to you what did
you think of outer range season 1 and
what are your thoughts and theories
leave them in the comments below i love
reading them also if you enjoyed outer
range and you haven't seen dark on
netflix it's my favorite time traveling
show and i have tons of videos on that
thanks for watching everyone for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at think story yt and
until next time remember
luke would you fetch me kamado
you